Thank you to Chromebook for sponsoring this video.
[Music]
- We got this.
- Yeah, we got this.
[Alarm]
- You know, I never really thought that our communication was awful.
- But he uses no emojis whatsoever.
- ... I was wondering if you would like to purchase...
- ... a solo ...
- And so how am I supposed to tell that you--
- Okay
[Both] Three, two, one...
[Office phone ringing]
[Message received]
- Hi!
- Hey, how are you?
You look so pretty by the way.
- Oh my gosh! Thank you!
- Where you are looks gorgeous.
- Yeah, it's ... so amazing here.
[Agony crying]
- Oops, sorry about that.
[Agony continues]
[Uncomfortable energy]
[Phone ringing]
[Phone vibrating]
- Like hours on in. I have like--
- No, no. It's not, it's like--
- Yeah, but--
- You did it again.
- I told you multiple times...
- No...
[Cheering]
[Phone vibrating]
[Party horn]
[Party dying]
[Phone vibrating]
Thank you so much again to Chromebook for sponsoring this video.
I used it all throughout production from shot listing, storyboarding, and dealing with so many schedules.
Plus, I love using that stylus to
just draw on everyone's photo.
If you want to see the making of this video, be sure to check it out on the Chromebook YouTube channel.
I'm Anna Akana. Bye.